so first thank you everyone for being
here and staying for the workshop
portion and hanging in with us during
the fire alarm and all the other good
stuff you can tell we're academics
because we have handouts so feel free to
take notes or not but I'm gonna let Greg
do the introduction about the theme of
the talk and then I'm gonna tell you a
little bit about how stoicism helped me
as a person but then also as a partnered
person and then Greg will do the same
we'll do a little bit of a touch base
and then to sort of just address any
fears a couple people during the firearm
said I don't know if I like workshops
like what's this workshop gonna move up
because I don't want to do group work so
you will not have to give any
testimonials or anything like that we
will have you talking to one another a
little bit but what you say to one
another is private unless you feel like
sharing it but we do want to talk a bit
about kind of how relationships play out
whether it's partnered relationships or
romantic relationships of a different
kind or you know work relationships all
of these things kind of impact the heart
but we will be talking almost
exclusively about our relationship and
what we've learned and how stoicism
impacted it in a positive way okay so
this last year I presented this workshop
at stoical on in London Andy and I are
supposed to present together and
unfortunately you couldn't fly so so we
did it and there were actually some
funny jokes in the video of that because
I think I said something about how this
is like something to do with
relationships but this is this is a talk
that we give quite frequently now it's
interesting because the ancients Stoics
if you read them they don't say anything
about dating or about you know match.com
or tinder or any of those sorts of
things and most of what they have to say
has to do with marriage and what they
have to say is pretty traditional you
know don't cheat on your spouse
amuse Sonia's Rufus you know the purpose
of marriage is procreation but also to
have intimacy to develop a full
relationship and so there's a very
normative thing for that but I think we
can take what they have to say and
expand an outward to other partner in
relationships so this could be very
useful for people who are not in a
relationship but would like to be in a
relationship or I've had a string of
relationships that didn't turn out the
way that they want to and they can do
sort of an after-action report about
that you know maybe it maybe it is you
but maybe it's done you know it's worth
thinking about these sorts of things so
the ancient Stoics actually have we've
got some you know practices and
perspectives that we're gonna bring up
that could be helpful for people these
are just sort of scratching the surface
I think an entire book could be written
about what stoicism could contribute to
first of all you know dating or being
you know on your own being you know
wishing that you could be dating but not
being in that pool the actual dating
going through the entire courtship
process when to say that's enough of
that
and find somebody else being in a a
committed relationship and all of the
things that that brings I think the
stoicism has a lot to contribute that
hasn't been mined sufficiently there are
some cool blog posts out there about
that and I will I will mention that that
Massimo Pigliucci answers questions
about those sorts of things
giving stoic dating advice so you might
check his stuff out I'm going to turn it
over to Andy for a moment to talk about
her experiences and our relationship and
yeah so I found stoicism a little bit by
accident I'm somebody who's been really
curious about the human mind for a very
long time and trying to figure out how I
could better understand my own right I
love a problem I love a challenge I also
love to find solution
I'm kind of operationally oriented but
also very creatively oriented and so I
find that those two pieces of myself can
be in conflict quite a bit what it led
to
ultimately was this kind of core center
where those two things joined where I
sort of thought that if I felt like I
had control over self our environment as
it turned out or others as it also
turned out that I somehow was kind of
mastering life right like the the
mistaken idea that if I could dictate or
control a situation
I actually was living better than if I
couldn't and one of the things that I
found happened was well for myself first
and then I'll talk a little bit about
how this impacts us I found that there
was great relief in reading studying and
learning about writers and thinkers and
practitioners who suggested that we look
at what we can control and what we can't
control particularly with epictetus the
passage about how we're playing a part
that helped me probably more than
anything else and I gave a talk a couple
of years ago about that and one of the
things I said is I've had a lot of
different careers so I was a building
super in New York City I'm an academic I
you know slung burgers and hash I've
delivered papers I've done all kinds of
interesting things that was the
assistant dolphin trainer at the
Milwaukee County Zoo when we still did
dolphin show like I did all kinds of
really cool jobs and I always felt
myself kind of almost trying them on
like I was an actor in a play and that
was how I came to tolerate some of the
worst jobs that I've had and it's also
how I came to really more thoroughly
enjoy some of the better jobs that I had
the things that I felt I was called to
do and when I took a step back and
recognize that while marriage itself
isn't a job or you know partnership
isn't a job it has many of the same
components there's expectations there's
things you ought to do ought not to do
there's ways in which you need to
connect with another person that shows
respect for that other person their
desires distinct from your own desires
finding a way to meet kind of a happy
medium if you will with someone else who
full disclosure is also incredibly
strong-willed like the two of us are
probably the
perfect pairing in part because we need
to work through all our stuff together
and as individuals I am incredibly bossy
I guess I'll just say right like I know
I know when I'm right and I want to be
right and that's something that I
struggle against so is this guy over
here right we're both very much
well workers achievers and thinkers and
so when I think I have the best idea and
he thinks he has the best idea and those
ideas are like this thankfully because
of so sysm for me at least I've been
able to take a different approach I've
been able to stop trying to control the
situation I've been able to listen more
effectively I've been able to assume
what would be most helpful to Greg as a
person not Greg as my friend not Greg
the guy went to high school with not
Greg as my spouse not Greg the guy I
lead workshops with like seeing him as
an actual independent person was
something that I struggled with and
because of Stoicism and the idea of
really keeping my control out of his
area I found that I was a better
listener a better partner and a better
friend to him and to others and so one
of the things that I found is that the
more I practice stoicism in my daily
life the more I actually like my life
the more I'm able to take frustrating
situations at work for example and just
sort of take a step back and just say
well that's that's what it is right now
and what can I be grateful for I can be
grateful for the fact that I have
employment that I get to use my mind in
my day to day life that I get to you
know solve problems with others that I
get to engage creatively that I get to
help create curriculum or have
conversations like this but it's a daily
sort of practice and I don't always
succeed by any means right you all saw
me smiling as we were coming in and put
your name take a pressure welcome thanks
for being here and then when we came
back in and had to set up the lunch
right some of that like isn't this
lovely we're all here together to think
talk you know and engage the mind flow
right out the window and I had an idea
about how the back table should be set
up and Greg had his idea and I was like
I only did this for a living right like
hurt myself say that there's like wow
you know that's great so it is something
that comes up you know in daily life and
thankfully I have a partnership with
somebody who's equally invested in
trying to find solutions that are
respectful but also autonomous and you
know allow us to kind of work within our
spaces most effectively while also
championing the other person for what
they're really good at so that's a lot
but I'm just gonna add three things this
is all such a big surprise it's a here
Andy brought up failing at things and I
wasn't actually going to talk about this
in the workshop but this has come up a
lot in the stoic fellowship failure is
inherent to any transformative process
and early on in it you fail a lot and
then you fail less often and less often
and you see the stoic authors talking
about this Seneca and and epictetus in
particular you know you get knocked down
well you have to get back up again and
get back in the fray and you can't say
oh it didn't work for me you have you
know well you can you have a choice but
if you do that you know what the the
what that path leads to and not allowing
ourselves to feel terrible when we do
fail Seneca says we have to be forgiving
with ourselves as we take stock of our
screw ups each day and I think that's
doubly so when you're doing it in in a
partnership and you know and we have
actually I do it for things so the other
thing I'll say along those lines Andy
and I are you know we're married
we're romantic partners we also work
together we also work together in the
same space and now we actually have a
very nice you know fairly sizeable
apartment so if she wants to be in one
place and I want to be on the other
floor we can do that although we can
both hear each other still but we lived
for a while it was about like 400 square
feet less than for her we lived at a
less than 400 square feet carriage house
apartment that means like above a garage
for five years yeah the first five years
of our being together in the same place
and those were some tough years yeah so
the third thing I'll say is Andy
mentioned we're both sort of like high
height you know you could call a high
achieving because we're constantly
striving we're also both angry people I
got into I got into stoicism in part
because I was looking for resources
within philosophy for anger management
and I found a lot of resources in the
Aristotelian tradition and some in the
Platonic tradition and then I started
reading people like Seneca and Epictetus
is like wow there's even more stuff here
this is really great and so we've been
applying those those insights sometimes
successfully sometimes unsuccessfully
more and more and more in our lives and
you know it's it's good to have I mean
you could have a partnership where
you've got somebody who's like totally
calm and you're the angry one and you
could work on your stuff and they're
supportive and that's nice right but
it's it's also it's it's kind of cool to
see people develop within the context of
a relationship and when you know that
you're struggling with some of the exact
same button-pushing problems there's a
sort of solidarity that can come with it
provided you don't get too competitive
with each other about it
and so that the last thing I'll say from
our experience we call it oh Henry
all of you are familiar with Oh Henry's
the the Gift of the Magi story
it's a Christmas story it's about two
two people who are poor as dirt and he's
got this pocket watch that he really
loves I think he came from his dad or
grandpa it's his only good possession
everything else he's got is garbage you
know and she has beautiful lustrous hair
and at Christmas time is coming and so
each of them sells off their prized
possession to buy the other person
something that they think they'll use so
she sells her hair to a wig maker to buy
this beautiful chain for the watch and
then when he opens it up he's like
do us any good because I sold the watch
to buy you a either a comer it's rock
yeah a comb and you know it's it's sort
of a tragedy and one act it's very
important I think to to avoid doing that
when you decide that you don't want to
just be angry with your spouse a
romantic partner or control them or
something like that then you can start
to try to you know see things their way
and do things that are gonna be good for
them but if you're doing it your way
your idea of what's good for them you
will inevitably O'Henry each other
yeah where you're you're both doing
things and then you've got all sorts of
new occasions for getting disappointed
and getting angry can't you see the nice
thing I'm doing for you yeah and then
they said well it's not a nice thing of
course it is yeah well no it's not
because it's not something that actually
meets their needs at the time that that
are in the way that that they they need
them met so I would say that's that's
something that stoicism has helped out
with quite a lot and then so before we
get into the the you know part where
we're gonna have you like talk with each
other one of the little bullet points in
there stoicism like other virtue ethics
says that we have some degree of control
over our thoughts and our emotions so
that's that's good news because it means
that we can change them if we're screwed
up and we're all screwed up in some ways
we can work on that if we can identify
where our thinking processes go off and
why we're having the emotional responses
that we are because we're assuming the
wrong thing or picking something up by
the wrong handle as epictetus says then
we can we can modify that over time you
can't of course snap your fingers and
say aha I figured it out now I'm calm
right you have to do habit modification
and changing habits is an integral part
of of stoic stoic stuff but having the
insights into how the emotions actually
work I mean this is part of why
Descartes wrote the passions of the soul
it's nice to actually have some
conception of what's going on under the
hood you know
so I think stoicism can help us avoid
O'Henry each other I can avoid it can
help us avoid lapsing into big fights
over things that we get angry about so
now we are going to do this this
exercise we call it the sounding board
and you don't have to fill in all these
things but I do want you to think about
your the challenges that you have when
it comes to romantic relationships
things you're afraid of things you're
hoping for and then what we can call
pain points where are the things that
you know they push your buttons
the things that keep you from from being
able to enjoy healthy and happy
relationships do you want to add
anything yes so we'll take probably
three to four minutes just to do some
jotting down and then after you let me
rephrase that we're gonna take three to
four minutes for you to jot down some
things and then turn to a neighbor and
discuss what you jotted down with the
neighbor so you can share as much or as
little as you'd like but the idea is to
just take a few moments to reflect on
your challenges your pain points you
know the little boats in the column
there and then share them with the
person sitting next to you and just talk
a little bit about kind of how those
manifests within your life
all right we're gonna reconvene so if
you just express your last few thoughts
about your your shared experiences so
who wants to share with the group we're
gonna ask for someone to volunteer about
a pain point first we're gonna talk
about pain points and hopes challenges
and fears will will save for another
time but if someone has a pain point yes
understood yeah that's not a projection
of the other person it's just my need
for how many of you would say that you
can relate to Travis like you need yeah
right yeah a lot of us are very outgoing
introverts I have this giant pair of
headphones that I put on and that's
Gregg's signal but I just need to be
alone and they're not even necessarily
plugged into anything like if the
headphones are on that's my signal to
just sort of say like cuz Greg would
talk I mean you met him right so I love
that about him don't get me wrong but
there are times when I also need a lot
of solitude because it takes a lot of
energy to like get this going right so
yeah definitely solitude is important
and how we communicate our need for
solitude is very important so I think
you know learning to connect with the
other person and to be open to the other
person that's what necessitated the
conversation of saying when I put my
headphones on I just need to be alone
because I'm feeling overstimulated not
as I did for the first part of our
partnership in marriage resent him for
talking I would be like what right
everything it was just you know would
you like a cup of coffee why would I
need a cup of coffee and I'm thinking
like this is really horrible right I
have a partner who's asking if I want
something is tending to my needs so it's
just one of those things where you do
have to learn also how to communicate
that need for solitude in a way that
sort of invites the other person to
share their perspectives and
sup with something that is not about you
controlling the situation right that's a
great one other pain points yeah respect
is huge and then you know in that case
sometimes like with a the Ellis thing
that they're talking about earlier
sometimes you actually aren't being
respected right then you have to figure
out what what you're going to do about
that sometimes it can be picking the
thing up by the right ear on handle we
were talking you know with the old Henry
egg thing right if you have to show
respect to the person in the way that
they they want it I think you know the
ancient Stokes didn't really talk that
much about this except Marcus who would
say somebody's doing something wrong
go ahead and tell them because instead
of just getting ticked off at them
you're you're actually giving them a
chance to adjust and then it's not you
know after that point you you can't
control what they're going to do but you
know I guess a lot of this comes down to
communication rational communication
doesn't it yeah and also recognizing if
you're in a partnership where your
dominant need is respect and their
dominant need is also respect and that
can be another one of those things where
you have to navigate and negotiate
that's that's definitely the two of us
like there's my language of like
whatever like I think love languages
came up over the lunch I was talking to
someone else absolutely respect 100% and
I think that both of us really need that
and so when we're in an area where
conflict could occur or does occur does
occur how we manage that respectfully is
super important and I think one of the
things that's kind of funny is over time
you can tell we're sort of like still
growing in this area
I guess because I'll say things like boy
that could have been a really big fight
like two years ago and then we like
high-five for it not turning into a
fight you know you have to celebrate
your accomplishments because it's hard
work it's definitely hard work that's
true yeah yeah another pain point okay
yeah time out having enough time or
well one person wants to do a certain
activity and the other person wants to
do another yeah and like what Seneca
said time is a very precious resource we
were willing to give our time when other
things like money or yeah and you can
always get more money back but you can't
get more time alright Jim how do you
navigate that how do you navigate that
[Music]
well yeah I mean the time you chose to
spend here today is a perfect example
right we're all in communion together
talking about this we've shared ideas
we've listened to different people
present different aspects of this
experience and stoicism and I think that
you know when you find a person where
your time and what you look forward to
doing is aligned with theirs is
absolutely much more rewarding right
because then we can enjoy these things
together but I'll also sort of add one
other thing and that's when a lot of the
things are aligned right like I enjoy
everything Greg enjoys Greg doesn't
necessarily enjoy everything Andy enjoys
so that then also becomes a way where
you can create some space of
understanding that goes beyond that kind
of O'Henry situation right and then
learning to enjoy some of the things
that your partner enjoys is part of that
maybe putting on that role for that day
or being willing to at least assume a
role that isn't necessarily familiar to
your own so that you can express that
value to the other person yeah so hopes
what are some of the hopes that you have
yeah that's very important yeah yeah
will you tell us a little bit more about
what that looks like
yeah communication is effort is a really
critical point I think it you know this
this may sound a little strange there's
you know they say that well there's
always more fish in the ocean there's
never been more fish in the ocean than
there are right now and given that we
have all these other ways of connecting
with people you know dating apps for
example there's a lot of people who now
are meeting themselves meeting other
meeting their partners electronically
right and it better you know better not
just be completely electronic or it's
not not completely developing but
there's there's often a lot of
components with that I think a lot I
think many people they they settle in
relationships and it might seem like
stoicism would say well you should
settle you know you you get a partner
and they're not everything that you'd
like well you know good opportunity to
sort of like you know be stoic and and
give things up and all that but I don't
think that's I mean the stoicism teaches
us that we should be fully developing
our human nature and I think if you're
living as a stoic you would want
somebody else was doing similar things
and so and and now you can it's easier
to find other people who are doing those
things than it was I think in the past
when like we'd meet mostly meet people
in the workplace or at a bar or where
else the grocery store yeah yeah so and
so reciprocity knowing what it is that
you want from the other person and being
willing to say to them you know here's
another kind of thing I'll say to in
negotiations and I'm not saying romance
should be a negotiation but there is
something to this being a being willing
to walk away and say I don't put up with
this from from you know there here's a
thing that I'm just not going to go
along with then people can say oh yeah I
guess I'm I'm not willing to give you
this so see you later
or maybe they'll promise some some
things in which case you can see whether
the promise actually makes sense or
they'll say holy crap they're serious
about this
I better figure out how I'm gonna do
this right yeah
I think I think to the other from them
from the store fellowship meetings that
we had early on one of the sticking
points that I think created a lot of
sort of internal conflict for people was
the passage where it's saying like don't
love your child or your family too much
just accept that they'll die and when
they're die you know and and somebody
talked about that in the lightning round
I think in some ways I've had to put my
ideas into the role of actual children
or people or you know and just let my
ideas die because not every idea is
worth you know fighting for and not
every idea actually needs to be like I
joke Roenick so we don't have to be
samesies samesies all the time because
initially it was sort of like that's how
we showed our alignment and our loyalty
to one another was that if I liked this
he liked this or if I felt this way he
felt this way that's a very immature
psychological position we know that
right
but when you're when you're entering
into a relationship and you're trying to
navigate that space being willing to let
your ideas pass and your you're sort of
obsessions pass can be a very positive
way to actually practice that side of
Stoicism I think yeah you know Plato
very early on said that people's ideas
are like their children they hate you
know you've got an idea you heat other
people criticizing it and you know you
want to keep it at all cost but but then
you know most ideas are you know we well
this is where we can start getting into
stoic perspectives and practices not all
ideas are actually going to be true and
so how do we how do we determine that so
should we launching so I picked out four
we have sort of a hodgepodge of things
as we've been developing this this
workshop and doing it in different
places a bunch of different stoic
perspectives and practices can be useful
and we're going to go through these kind
of quickly we can we've got time for Q&A
at the end and there's space for notes
you know if you've got questions about
this so one of the first things is
dealing with what we call appearances
and then our own expectations
appearances is a technical term in stone
Fantasia it's also translated
impressions imaginations
so when Epictetus says to every harsh
appearance say this he's talking about
that sort of thing there are things that
are coming to us from the outside they
often do you have some of our own
judgments built into them so that that
same quote - from Ellis forget I think
Kevin brought it up that it's it's not
it's not the things themselves but our
thinking that the things are harming us
that that harms us right
that's about appearances we have we have
we have the the appearance that
something is bad for us so we want to
deal with these rationally and that's
central to stoicism the proper dealing
with or use of appearances Epictetus
says that's what's germane to human
beings as opposed to other animals we
have the capacity to step back and say
whoa is this what's really happening
here so you know you can see how this
would be very helpful when it comes to
romantic relationships both things that
are enticing us and things that are that
were averse to so if we look at the
desire side of the first you know we've
all known what it's like to be
infatuated with somebody in the very
early part of a relationship before we
get to know what they're really like
which often helps not be infatuated with
them later but you know as we get to
know some people we actually might get
more infatuated what are some of the
common things that come out of being
infatuated some of the judgments that go
along with that oh if I can't have this
person my life is incomplete alright or
what they think really really really
matters as a matter of fact that matters
more than anything else in the world
this is this is part of eros of romantic
love isn't it the Stoics wouldn't say
well get rid of that that's no good
whatsoever but they would say well let's
be rational about
you know you can feel what you're
feeling but then you should also step
back and say how much of this actually
makes sense what else did we have with
their own testing appearances Epictetus
tells us we got to test them so that
could be very useful with adverse things
like Andy says something and I don't
like the way that she says it the sound
of her voice and how she's looking at me
and well this has been a major issue
with us when Andy is in pain then you
know she talks in a different way than
when she's feeling good right and so if
I take the way that she's talking to me
is having to do with me rather than her
own internal sensations then I can that
appearance is she's you know being mean
to me she's talking to me in a way I
don't like and then you know I can
respond immediately back and and almost
by reflex action and then you're off to
the exactly and then we're both like why
are you such a jerk you know no why are
you such a jerk right now if we can take
a pause which is what we've had to do
quite often and ask each other are you
ticked off at me are you are you
dismissing what I have to say then we
can get some things worked out because
usually it turns out we're not sometimes
we are you know but then we can say well
why are you ticked off right assigning
the responses of one to another right
failing to kind of see that this is a
unique person not anyone else with whom
I've dealt before in my life I think
we've all done it with the baggage of
past relationships with us and when X
happened it meant that this party was
doing this thing over here and Bragg and
I have somewhat comedic they said to one
another from time to time I'd love to
meet this Andy or this Greg you're
having the relationship with right now I
don't know who that is but you know part
of it to me could you let them yeah a
little bit or assume that they know what
they're talking about but the
effectivity of expression becomes an
important part to I we both teach as
I've mentioned and you know both of us
do a lot with faculty development and
one of the
that I was really keen on getting
faculty that I was working with to do is
to record themselves giving lectures so
that they could become more dynamic
lecturers so I said I'll you know I'll
record my class to show you how this is
because some of them were very afraid of
seeing the film on tape and I had mine
playing and I was like what am I saying
I must be really angry or something like
that because there was no sound but my
face was kind of like this and I
realized that my listening intently and
giving my full attention to a person
face is exactly the same as my I'm very
angry with your face and so sometimes we
have to ask the other person to give us
that feedback that is super important
and hear what they're saying right
because when I'm really listening to
Greg I look like I'm really angry with
Greg and that was something that we
navigated for awhile right or when he's
paying attention he's looking off in the
distance and I'm like where's the eye
contact so sometimes the expectation and
the picking up by the handle can be as
simple as a facial expression or a
response
you know when I'm agreeing I'll say yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and when I say it
just like that what he's hearing is that
I'm trying to rush him through or I'm
dismissing him and I'm emphatically
agreeing with him so we had to have
meta-level conversations about what our
conversations were actually saying to
one of those very important but they're
super important exactly because it
helped us to build a better
understanding so so that that's a good
segue into understanding emotions
we've talked a good bit about that today
for the Stoics emotions are always
connected with judgments there is no
emotion that doesn't involve some sort
of judgement and they can be expressed
more or less propositional II there's
also the affective side how it feels
right but this really gives us a great
handle because when we unpack what it is
that you know why it is that we feel the
way that we do what does it mean to be
angry in this situation or disappointed
or anxious or anything like that
and we we sort of lay it out we can now
approach it and understand it and start
thinking is this rational or is this you
know unfounded is this just coming out
of my old habits is this because of old
relationships
this you know baggage that I'm carrying
around or you know cultural assumptions
so the Stoics thought that many emotions
were very problematic Daniel was talking
about you know good you know good
emotions right so some of the good
emotions they're they're always gonna be
rationally felt that means that reason
which is not so some sort of cold cool
rationality calculating everything it's
really you know sort of a direction to
the good it tells us this is a good way
to feel so you know rational desire
places in the Greek that the Stoics used
for that it means that you do feel
desire so you know I desire to spend
time with Andy I don't want to strip
away desire altogether but if my desire
for spending time with her starts to get
me being you know kind of pissy because
she is doing work stuff which was in the
calendar already that you know I should
be taking a look at then then we've got
a problem
right there's also a rational fear there
are things that we ought to be concerned
with doesn't mean that we ought to allow
anxiety to run our lives or anything
like that
rational joy is also something that the
Stoics think that we should feel they
call it ha tourism in greek and you know
it's there's a whole different whole
bunch of modalities of how we could feel
this and i think in you know partnered
relationships that's something we ought
to be striving for you know we ought to
love each other we ought to want to
spend time with each other we ought to
have concern for for each other all of
those are good it when we start feeling
other things that's when we get into
problems now the Stoics as we mentioned
said anger is never good i don't
actually buy that myself I'm more of an
Aristotelian in that sense rational
emotive behavior therapy also doesn't go
completely down that stoic path bought
the Stoics give us an awful lot of
helpful ways to find out why we're angry
and to start trimming it back even
though the people like Aristotle to say
anger can be good sometimes he doesn't
think it's good most of the time you
know you've got to be really careful
with with anger Seneca says anything
that you can accomplish with anger you
can probably also accomplish with reason
and you're not going to have so many
well we're going off course because of
it right so another thing we wanted to
talk about in this as well is I I have
my emotions that I have to understand
and manage and stoicism can help with
that and then Andy has emotions and I
want her to feel certain ways quite
naturally but if I desire that too
strongly and I start demanding that she
feel things when I want her to feel them
and the way that I want her to feel them
and then express them in the in the same
ways and stuff like that
that's where we really get into a lot of
trouble and for those who are not in a
relationship but are say dating or
considering something like that that's
something to you know pay attention to I
would say right being too concerned with
what the other person is feeling or you
might say being concerned with it in
ways that are not productive
you know you can think about well what
do I want her to feel I want her to feel
joy I want her to feel you know desire
in the right ways I want her to feel
fear when it's when it's appropriate
ideally like her not to have to feel
fear at all but there are some times
like when the fire alarm goes off you
probably should get the hell out of the
building right we and in our apartment
because it's being remodeled in the
building we've had a lot of fire alarms
you know
so that's that's all I have to say about
that one do you want to add anything
yeah I think the thing about cultivating
good emotions is the point that I would
like to just add something to I think it
was Eric and the lightning talk right
you're talking about gratitude and yeah
and the idea that you can't really be
angry if you're grateful I think it came
up in a few different talks looking at
the perspective of you know just sort of
what you're feeling and where it sits
right so one of the things that I've
gotten great value out of is saying to
Greg thank you for your feedback which
initially could have been replaced with
a very not so nice thing right it
originally was what I wanted to say
something altogether different I was
like oh that's interesting thank you for
your feedback because I had to remember
that feedback is a gift right someone's
telling you kind of what what you're
presenting is but the other thing is
that I think he's done a great job of
doing that with me as well because when
you have two very strong personalities
the way in which you navigate space is
complicated and so I had an idea of what
joy should look like he had an idea of
which I should look like most of those
things were aligned in areas where they
were not aligned it was a good deal of
conversation right sometimes a
conversation sometimes conflict
sometimes you know tears were involved
but when you get to know another person
in a real heart level and you're open to
those things I think the more that you
can see what you're hearing from them as
a gift and as sort of a generous
expression the easier it is to navigate
it because then if I'm grateful for the
fact that I have someone who's telling
me their thoughts I'm less inclined to
see those thoughts as oppositional to my
reality I'm less inclined to see them as
oppositional to my own growth right I
have not enjoyed a lot of the work that
we've had to do together in order to get
to the point that we are now but I have
enjoyed the results of that work and
keeping my kind of focus on how that
impacts the ability to connect with
another person on an emotional level has
benefited my relationship with my
siblings with my parents with
my you know co-workers it's just easier
to engage in the world when you're not
seeing everything as in the front to
your worldview yeah so Andy brought up
the dichotomy of control a little bit
earlier so all I think all of you are
pretty familiar with the dichotomy of
control this notion that is Epictetus
says some things are in our control or
in our power or literally up to us at
pame in and other things are not and
being able to actually distinguish
between these and then stick to that
distinction that's that's the harder
part right
having the list on one side and the list
on the other side that's easy but that
actually putting that into practice it's
quite difficult and if you think about
the things that he says aren't in our
control one of them is how other people
act how they feel you know what they
they do and what he calls reputation or
the Doakes up fits under that too but
you think about the things that couples
fight about you know what are what are
the biggest things yeah it's not sex
it's actually money that's one of the
biggest things then of course whether to
have kids or not I'm treat the kids sex
can also be something that people fight
about you know what their status is in
the community all those things are what
what the Stoics called indifference
which doesn't mean that we should like
say well they don't matter at all right
if I if I decide to like you know go
into class and just you know swear all
the time and something like that
I think Andy would probably call me on
that and say that's an imprudent thing
to do what are you having a midlife
crisis or something like that but it's
less important than the relationship
itself you know or I mean if you were to
I don't start doing that with clients
you know yes wearing a blue streak on
the phone I would ask you what's going
on but you know it's still less
important than the actual relationship
what we do have control over is our own
you know desires and aversions
and choices and the assumptions that we
make I don't actually control what what
she thinks and I think a lot of our
early arguments and fights and conflicts
had to do with trying to push each
other's buttons to try to get certain
responses I think it can be common for
people who maybe find one another I mean
we so we knew each other in high school
but we weren't dating in high school we
worked in the same place without
realizing it more than one than I do
yeah in the 90s like we kept
reconnecting without connecting and then
ended up you know reconnecting through
Facebook that's this whole long story
that I won't bore you with but the thing
is is that it was sort of this feeling
of like okay so now we are together
together after all of this time and life
is shorter now or you know 40 now and
like how are we going to navigate this
space and make the most of it and so
there was a lot of desire on both of our
parts to kind of squeeze it all out
right like everything we could out of
every moment because now we had found
each other and so there was this
wonderful kind of like expectations very
high very high and and when we first
started to feel one another's
expectations without realizing it it was
almost as if the devastation was was you
know worse than had it been different so
I think that part of our early conflicts
and something that we've definitely
grown from is this idea of not holding
someone to the ideal that we created
without their consent or involvement
right the vision that I had of my
perfect Greg wasn't really Greg and I
never asked him to contribute to it it
was sort of like this is what I expected
him to be and I think vice versa and
vice versa yeah so when we really got to
into the kind of like hard work of
saying well actually I don't like that
at all or this is what I want or you
know I'd actually prefer this over this
the freedom that that allowed even
though we were sharing different things
than what the other person originally
expected of us was pretty powerful yeah
and you know time does factor into this
as well if I want Andy to change in some
important way or she wants me to change
in some important way it's it's not
gonna happen on the timetable that I
dictate to her or or vice versa it's
gonna happen when the other person has
come to the point where like yeah this
this actually does matter to me and you
can understand that through the
dichotomy of control you can't you can't
force another person into changing on
your schedule right yeah or prioritizing
things about by either and I think the
other thing is sometimes you discuss
what your expectations are with the
person and you recognize that it's
perhaps not even change that you're
looking for it's a different expression
of what currently is the case yeah you
know finding a different way to
articulate an issue rather than actually
trying to change something fundamental
about that person um now I do want to
say something about these indifference
so you know from stoic perspective the
things they call indifference or
externals it's not as if they don't
matter at all they're just not the
things that are gonna make us completely
happy so wealth is a great example right
if I'm frivolous frivolously spending
money we're not able to do other things
that we we would enjoy it's not a good
thing for me to be imprudently spending
money however much money we have in the
bank isn't going to make us happy but it
is something that we want to be prudent
in dealing with and we have to be on the
same page as a couple with respect to
these of difference so I in terms of
like dating this would be one of the key
things right you figure out while you're
dating how do you see values like
physical health how do you see values
like you know financial stability what
else
social status we didn't you know plans
for for post work or
I think that oftentimes people don't
think about that too right this idea of
what you're gonna do after your career
path kind of wraps up how do you want to
spend the life of leisure that you will
hopefully have at some point and I've
seen a lot of people spend years
together in a marriage that was
seemingly happy and then split up
because the idea of what happened after
work was completely different
one person wants to travel the world the
other person wants to play Bunco you
know and it's just like how do you
reconcile that so yeah played Bunco
elsewhere the Bunco crews exactly so the
last practice / / perspective we're
gonna talk about roles and relationships
and duties the Stoics stress the need to
recognize what our duties are and one of
the really cool things that you see in
epictetus very heavily enough that that
somebody actually wrote a book called
the role ethics of epictetus brian
johnson not to be confused with with the
you know the brian johnson of ac/dc the
one who's at Fordham but it's also there
in Cicero it's also there in Seneca the
the notion is the the relationships that
we have the the names of the
relationships tell us what our what our
duties are in relation to other people
so understanding you know I think
Epictetus
talks about it as if it's a little bit
easier than it is like you know what
does it mean to be a father what does it
mean to be a husband what does it mean
to be a friend these are things that we
have to work at to figure out we often
get confused about this but the Stoics
would say that this you know considering
these matters does help us you know
probably we need to add what does it
mean to be a good father what does it
mean to be a good you know lover
romantic partner whatever we're going to
say so we have to consider what our what
our actual duties are towards our
partners notice where it's less focused
on what are what are her duties to me
you know from my perspective and more on
what are my duties to her and vice versa
because otherwise we're getting
ourselves once again you
to sources of conflict and you know we
should think about the the expectations
when it comes to other people's duties
that we have that's that's one place
where we got into a lot of struggles
right and we need to think about what
our partners need not what we want them
to need so you know the here's a great
example neither of us actually fit this
profile but all of you know people like
this the caretaker right the person who
really needs a romantic partner that
they can fix that they can take care of
that they can be there for because it's
satisfying some-some needs on their own
part now you know there there are plenty
of people who be like Oh sounds great to
me
you know give me the chicken soup and
I'm not going to do any work anymore and
and you can you can take care of me
that's not a very good relationship but
then there's other people who are like
you know that's not really what I was
looking for in a partner I'm looking
more for say an intellectual
collaborator or
as we originally said we're gonna write
the world together right though those
sorts of needs that we have Andy has
legitimate needs I should make sure that
I'm conscious of and try to try to
address those needs as much as possible
not the needs that I want her to have
and you know it may sound well that's a
no-brainer
right but this happens over and over and
over again in relationships so I think
part of what it means for us to fulfill
our roles is to be able to discern what
the actual needs of other people are
what do you wanna yeah I think the thing
that the one thing that Greg and I do is
sort of a habit that I think has served
us well is actually check in with one
another and often on long drives we'll
just put our recording on on the phone
and just talk about we want what we want
the rest of our life at that moment to
look like right so what's the kind of
ultimate career achievement that you
would like to have like we just we throw
it all out there as big dreams and then
we talk about what's possibly attainable
at that point and then we talked about
how we could support
person so it's some interesting
goal-setting but what it ultimately
reflects is the role that we're going to
play to and for one another at that time
and so over time what we've been looking
to build has changed and I think that
you know being able to sit here together
with everyone to have this event to
engage in dialog is incredibly
gratifying to both of us it's something
that we really enjoy it you know is I
think good work and it's just fun right
so that might not be everybody's cup of
tea and luckily the two of us really
enjoyed doing this together but if
suddenly something changed and I no
longer wanted to be a part of this part
of the relationship would have to be
where we navigated what that looked like
in different terms five years from now
because people do change and
expectations do change and you know I
think that that's something that we've
actually gotten pretty good at because
we were so terrible at it at the
beginning you know we had such different
expectations of what being comfortable
was going to look like or certain things
happened and we've had opportunities
that we've been able to seize and
support one another fully in that and
experience a joy in that and you know
that's something that I think was new to
us in terms of past partnerships that
we'd had we hadn't had people
necessarily support us and the things
that we were really you know dedicated
to or really wanted to do and so when we
found that we had so many similarities
it was very easy to think that well then
this should also be simple and this
should also be similar over here so I
think in terms of the expectations and
what we need and what we want for one
another what I want most is for Gregg's
to feel fulfilled and be joyful and have
a happy and good life and to be able to
define that on his own terms right and I
know that he wants the same thing for me
and what that looks like in some areas
is very similar and in other areas it's
not as similar but it's still mutually
supportive and that's because of the
communication and the willingness to
release one another of expectations I
don't get to define what joy or
happiness looks like for him but I
recognize it when I know he's
experiencing it and then I
can support it because I'm paying
attention and he does the same for me
and so I consider that to be probably a
pretty lucky way to spend your life in
partnership right it could be very
different than that and I've seen a lot
of relationships where that's not the
case we've both been in relationships
where that's not the case but as you
know as you look forward knowing that
you can walk down the road with somebody
who shares that very important
perspective I think is is just something
that I see is a real gift so you know
the last thing I'll say - and then we'll
start taking questions is you know
somebody might say well what if my
partner isn't a stoic right and that's
probably going to be the case
you know if you there's no I think that
well there is a Facebook group like
stoic dating or something like that
what's up yeah there you go there's
probably you know it's probably you know
a market for that sort of thing you'd
have to find some way to weed the the
you know though the non the sort of fake
Stoics from from people who are really
committed to it just like you would with
any other dating pool but one of the
challenges that you would probably face
and that's what this would go for
anything where you've got a genuine
commitment to some substantive way of
living is what do you do in the partner
doesn't see things that way you can't
force them into it you can bring them
along to events you know you can put
little you know pamphlets and things
like that but you can't you can't
necessarily get them to see that as a
value unless you're actually like living
it out in which case you know I think a
lot of people get attracted to stoicism
because they see somebody else not
necessarily romantic partner more often
like a co-worker or friend and they're
like you used to be a miserable sob what
what you know now you're actually kind
of a decent person what's going on here
another stoicism you know
and then they're like have you heard of
Marcus Aurelius you know if you heard of
Epictetus here take it take a look I
think that's that's part of what has to
happen and it's not gonna happen like
all at once you know instant conversions
usually don't stick it's the stuff we do
over and over again so is there anything
else that you want to say before you
just take questions yeah I mean I think
the whole notion of conversion to is
another thing just to kind of touch on
you can't really convert somebody into
thinking this way it has to be something
that comes from a natural process and so
you know it's it's great to share with
one another it's great to share ideas if
you know your partner isn't into this
whole thing right it can't feel like
you're forcing it on them either it has
to be something where you lead by
example and I think you know in our case
neither of us led we just sort of
struggled and found it and then decided
to start implementing it because it was
clear that we needed to do something
differently so the success of our
relationship where it stands right now
is a direct result of just how tough it
was to try and navigate the space of
bringing two people together who had
like very clear ideas on what life
should look like and it was a mutual
surrender not something where you know
Gregg won or Andy one or whatever
although it felt like that initially I
think for both of us for a good deal
cause I lost yeah I felt like we both
lost but I think you know whatever it is
that works the the biggest takeaway for
me is just being okay with being
uncomfortable for a little bit and
trusting that the process itself will
will resolve but if it that's very hard
that's true and and you know what they
call spiritual practices or
philosophical practices that that's one
of the things that go that you you have
to try it and you do it for a while and
then suddenly you start seeing results
that you couldn't have predicted at the
beginning yeah and you're like I guess
the stuff actually does work
so that's it yeah so let's take
questions and we'll stick around for a
while yeah nine years yeah yeah about
nine years little more than most of it
married
yeah little over nine years yeah
oh yeah okay
[Music]
yeah well I think part of that is you
know people some people retire and then
they're just like just hanging around
the house all day long right and that's
probably part of it the the people you
know who seemed most happy in retirement
are people who take on new things you
know and they're not just home all day
watching TV you know I mean even if you
are at home maybe you garden something
like that start learning a language you
know what do you think about yeah I
think we're lucky because we are in a
kind of class of people sort of scholar
partnership where we're doing a lot of
independent work but we're it's work of
the mind and we get to think and talk so
I mean we're just geeks that way right
so we're constantly talking about the
things that are of interest to us
whether it's over dinner or you know in
the car or whatever else so yeah yeah
after yeah
I mean I I knew about stoicism in part
because I you know studied it as an
undergrad a little bit and then I was
interested in anger management stuff
before we got together but I was you
know sort of looking at like ancient
philosophy and anger management in
general I wasn't trying to put it into
practice and then maybe the last four or
five years we've actually been like I
mean it's one thing to read it's another
thing to actually like to stick to it
yeah we were talking about it before we
were doing it yeah I mean it was like I
remember I think one of our earlier
conversations was in about like 2010 and
it was just sort of like well here's you
know so-and-so would say that this is an
interesting practice and the first time
Greg brought it up to me I was like I
don't care what so-and-so said like I am
about this right now like this is us and
that person can stay out of the
conversation for a little bit so I was
definitely more resistant to the idea of
implementing outside practice but once
we both sort of yeah I would say the
last four or five years and definitely
more over the last 18 months like I feel
like there's been sort of like
progressive you know growth spurts or
growth patterns yeah yeah you know
another thing too this is not so much
about relationships I mentioned you'll
fail a lot in applying stoicism and one
of the things that also happens is
hitting plateaus where you've made some
progress and then for months and months
and months you're like you know doing
things your mood doesn't like keep
getting better and better that's okay
because because there's there's usually
something going on underneath the
surface it provided you're actually
cooking with the practices it you know
sometimes if things have to gel a bit
and then you start seeing more
improvement
yes so in relationship when the
difference occurs between
it's a difference that each person the
bullets has something that is
they are yeah and they're very stubborn
I guess how would detect me that way
it's like that's the issue and maybe you
want to try to work with that partner to
negate it and try to maybe a practice
with maybe to maybe watch a little bit
and do something that's more
uncomfortable to what once
predisposition is too late they say
let's say you change one of your
behaviors like you start to get more
time when you like to have that so how
do you know like
it's a little too manufactured well I I
think one of the big problems we have is
placing too high a value on authenticity
today there is there is a real truth to
the fake it till you make it yeah with
any set of spiritual practices they're
gonna feel as you're saying manufactured
artificial weird at the start until it
becomes something where you I'm one even
become habituated and the others you can
see some useful results coming out of it
often surprising results
I don't know well I was gonna say when
you have a conflict of like we call it
core values it could be like let's see
let's say you're like a devoted stoic
and you're like the virtues that's what
really matters to me and your partner is
like making a ton of money is the most
important thing in the world well you're
never gonna see eye to eye on that and
you can say well I can get along with
you and all that but sooner or later
when it comes to decision making they're
going to decide things on that basis and
I don't want to be involved with that
and there may be cases where as a stoic
you would say well this relationship is
not going to not going to work when
you've got people who like you know they
are both committed to something like say
virtue but they have very different
understandings of it then they have to
then it you've got more you can work
with you know but it you know if you if
somebody is like totally concerned with
what the Stoics call externals like
social status or wealth or the beauty of
their body or something like that
there's you're really not going to be
able to do much with them I think you
know
I can do one yeah so I think for a very
long time when we would have conflict
and one of us would sort of agree to
support the other person yeah it would
be sort of saying well do you agree with
me and the answer would be I don't agree
with you but I'm going to do this anyway
because I know that it's important to
you and so I would say that that's kind
of how I'm reading your use of the word
authentic is sort of a genuine
transformation and so you know it's it's
that kind of thing we're like I wanted
you to want to change your mind on this
because you care about me so much and
instead you know learning to accept that
the person hasn't changed their mind and
they're still going to compromise and
give you what you're looking for and
that needs to be okay with you you can't
control the emotional sort of like
acceptance of it behind the scenes you
just have to recognize that you're
getting a gift because you're getting
end result but how the person feels
about end result is their business you
can't control that piece of it right you
can just gratefully accept that they're
trying to work with you to achieve a
combination at first though we
interpreted the other person is doing
that a passive-aggressive way yeah I'm
gonna go along with you on this because
you're totally wrong and so you're so
obstinate that I'm not going to change
your opinion yeah that wasn't helpful no
anything else yeah what did what in your
experience have you found the stoicism
in general societal or close no pushback
or hard self as
Buddhism you know a lot of yeah and
another modern society door more
attention to the commodity yeah a lot of
soul and it's hard to teach people how
to avoid being distracted all the time
because there are more of them all the
time
so what about the stores that larger
societal things that are like a hard
sell as an example maybe cover to
society selling society is saying you
should be this and stoicism says me not
so much
well stoicism has a corresponding notion
of attention Pro sulking you know focus
you could say and strictly speaking you
know we should be like paying attention
all the time to what we're what we're
doing and thinking and feeling and
working on it now of course we're not
you know but yeah there is there are a
lot of forces within society that make
it more difficult to to consistently
practice stoic approaches I mean you
know some of the notions that that we do
get from society like I should get
things my own way or or if so if my
partner isn't giving me everything that
I want then there's something
fundamentally wrong with the
relationship you know you know some some
things that I've wanted from Andy over
the course of time have been looking
back on it irrational and she was right
to push back and
and you can probably say the same I'm
imagining yes not all of my desires have
been rational yeah and and some have
been spurred by you know thinking about
prestige for example you know or worries
about what we were gonna do for money
that was it that was actually a big one
as entrepreneurs you know we deal with
clients and stuff like that we have very
different attitudes I believe that money
is abundant it will find us and we just
have to do what we're good at and it's
gonna work out like that's ridiculous
but I believe it my bones and it's
always worked out for me
yeah and I've always gone forward
thinking we can do this we can do this
we can do this and whatever it is we can
do it we can make it happen and Greg is
far less of that mindset and so we can
partner in that right and he can kind of
say what how will it work and you know
help me understand and I'm very much
about just you know keep moving forward
I'm operationally minded but I'm also
much more entrepreneurial in that way
you know where risk isn't something that
frightens me at all probably almost to a
degree that might not be the best
because I'm willing to jump and trust
the net will appear all the time when
you're in a couple on your jump you're
dragged you're taking your partner and
into Greg's credit he's been like where
are we going so yeah that's that's you
know - the other thing though I think
social media is a prime example of where
we're all over the place right so we put
up the hashtag and said hey if you're
doing it you know live stream whatever
that is meaningless though it's just
that it's become a form of cultural
currency and so you know we can say it's
great that all of these really wonderful
people yeah came together to talk about
this or we could get obsessed about
numbers or we could you know be like oh
we had a talk and only three people
showed up well those are the right three
people right and so sometimes you have
to kind of just change your perspective
on what you think is a sign of achieving
your goals and I think you're going to
be can bash
the other still icons and say we had
more people than you did yeah then we
had free lunch you charged people but
anyway yeah anything else because I know
we're running long until you thank you
so much for staying and yeah
is in the world things you don't know
that person might have already too much
work yeah maybe additions that are a lot
worse than that
but even if one person is a documents
callosity I think you can then start
recognizing that their disengagement or
their lack of policy or their anger or
you know their busyness might be that
helpful for their relationship and kudos
to the two of you that you've enabled
that way and with each of your class
phasing flying philosophies and only
start to make that work for yourselves
but then share the rest of us show you
high-five over that yeah
[Applause]
you